all right I woke up to Hannity tonight
we begin with the Fox News Alert and
breaking tonight according to our
sources the FBI recently conducted not
one but two searches at the University
of Delaware combing through Biden's
massive Trove of documents for
classified material no word yet on
whether any classified material was
located but the bureau is still going
through documents we're going to keep
you posted as this story continues to
unfold we were told originally it might
be the equivalent of two truckloads that
Biden had brought over to the the
university
also tonight big breaking news from Jim
Jordan surrounding big Tech and the
federal government he will join us and
tell us all about it and Nikki Haley she
will join us only hours after now
announcing her run for the presidency
we'll talk to her and the great one Mark
Levin will weigh in on Joe Biden China a
combination that is now more dangerous
than ever but tonight more direct
threats from the Communist Party of
China now you would think that they they
are the ones that shot down our spy
balloon at this point the way they're
acting on top of more Promises of
surveillance against us more spying
against us more hostility in the Pacific
and more pollution and more death and
more suffering don't forget it was China
that created covid-19 they Unleashed it
on the world knowingly over a million
Americans died in part because of China
if your parents died your grandparents
died your friends family members died
it's maybe because of that country's
sloppy authoritarian government make no
mistake the Communist Party of China is
a malignant threat to America and the
globe but the Biden Administration will
not hold them accountable for anything
raises questions how much money do they
do in business with them they won't even
dare say a bad word about China now some
on the left were more angry that when
President Trump called covet the China
virus then the fact that the government
of China remember they only allowed
people in Wuhan they could travel to the
rest of the world but they weren't
allowed to travel inside of China and if
you were outside of Wuhan you couldn't
fly into Wuhan that was the first travel
ban and meanwhile the current White
House is doing nothing about the
hundreds of thousands of Acres of
Farmland Ranch Land that China is buying
up often near our U.S military
installations they don't seem to care
about the 800 percent increase in
Chinese Nationals coming across a
southern border there have been 900
apprehensions since December alone and
they are definitely not stopping China
from paying off American universities
with millions and millions of dollars in
donations including you got it the
University of Pennsylvania the home of
the UPenn Biden center now the Biden
Administration is also ignoring China's
military expansion into Antarctica they
wouldn't even shoot down a Chinese spy
balloon as it hovered over our nuclear
sites a military basis for days on end
this week we're being told that the U.S
actually tracked the balloon this is
what they're telling us now from its
very origin when it took off from China
that is not what we were told last week
but if that is true that raises a whole
set of new questions meaning why did Joe
Biden wait eight days to take it down
before it actually flew over Alaska
airspace and Idaho and our ICBM missile
sites in Montana and other military
installations and allow it to Fly Over
States like Missouri and Kansas and
Kentucky all the way to the east coast
and the Carolinas apparently Biden just
what didn't think it was a major breach
oh that's right that's what he said
it wasn't even a major security bridge
for the United States just the fact that
the balloon came into the airspace and
flew over the country for so many days
oh look
the total amount of
intelligence Gatherings going on by
every country around the world is
overwhelming and the idea that a balloon
could Traverse uh break American
airspace is uh uh
anyway
this is not a major breach
it's not a major breach breach what
planet is he on now naturally the
remarks from his vice president they
weren't any better by the way she's now
representing by the way our country at
the Munich security conference God help
us all and today she told Politico that
the little balloon episode didn't impact
our relationship with China in any way
that's it that's not a major breach
didn't impact our relationship well
that's got to be news to China because
they have been threatening us all week
with retaliation for shooting down their
spy balloon off the coast of Myrtle
Beach now they should really be taking
Biden for you know thanking Biden for
allowing them to collect all that Intel
for eight straight days but the CCP they
know that it can bully the Biden
Administration that there won't be any
consequences whatsoever that's sad now
even on the administration's favorite
topic climate change China as usual they
get a free pass remember the Paris
climate Accords they are recognized as a
developing country as is India and Mew
China is polluting more than any other
country on the face of the Earth they
have a new coal-fired power plant that
goes online on average every 10 days and
the Biden Administration has no problem
asking you the American people to make
major sacrifices to reduce carbon by a
minuscule amount but they won't even
broach the topic with China under Biden
China always gets a free pass now today
Senator John Kennedy pointed this out
during a hearing with so-called climate
experts take a look at this
we spend 50 trillion dollars
Europe cooperates
most western democracies cooperate
but India and China don't how much will
our 50 trillion dollars lower World
temperature we're in this together
Senator we have to get the world to work
together how much I understand I get
that okay how much lower World
temperatures
if China and India do not help yes I
don't know faced with a policy okay
where China does something that's not in
its best interest but it does it because
it's in the global best interest
do you think president XI would do that
I think that President XI understands
that we have to work together to address
this Global problem yes I do and it will
be in the best interest of China to work
with the United States to address so you
think the answer is yes
I think the answer is that it's in
China's best interest to work with the
rest of the world to address this
problem as it is in the United States
biggest interest to work with the rest
of the world to address this problem do
you create harmonized incentives you
believe in the tooth fairy
no sir do you believe in the Easter
Bunny no sir you believe that Jimmy
Hoffa died of natural causes no sir okay
uh no sir hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else